it's okay I'm fine I've done crazy hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Michael Cera you
know him is George Michael on the hit
show Arrested Development and
award-winning roles in films like Juno
Superbad Scott Pilgrim vs. the world and
many more and you can catch him in the
Waverley gallery premiering on Broadway
this fall Michael Cera welcome to the
show thank you how are you a spicy food
I like spicy food I think there was this
amazing Thai restaurant in LA called
Jitlada and they have like at the back
of the menu for like something challenge
and you took it on and me and a friend
did it
my friend Eric Idle standing me we sat
and we got mussels you can get anything
with this sauce and they bring you like
a pink like pepto-bismol milkshake
I like bunch of you know cabbage and
stuff and you just go bite for bite and
it's like okay let's do another it's
like this weird ride you take with your
friend and we did that well let's go on
another ride man
[Music]
can I ask you how you're sitting on this
store are you feet both on the middle
bar oh yeah they got one foot on the
ground and I don't feel like I'm sitting
you know I mix it up every once in a
while I feel like throwing it off
there's this shadow style with it let's
straddle the thing that's like the leg
of the table and just really actually
join you here whatever makes you
comfortable Michael do I look more
comfortable that's good
so want to start by taking it back to
the early days when you are a
nine-year-old doing commercial auditions
by the hundreds in the highly
competitive world of child commercial
acting did you ever get backstabbed or
double-crossed by another fifth grader
there were like two kids who were like
the kobe bryant's of like the child
commercial ring mm-hm and they just
booked everything and you'd go to a
commercial it would be like dozens of
kids and all their moms and you knew
their moms too and some of the moms for
extra intimidating weird but there was
like if you saw like looka there even
like well [ __ ]
why'd I even come I might as well go
yeah this is a wash and then in our
research we found an old Pillsbury
commercial that you did early on you
actually got to poke the doughboys belly
that was the second job I ever got and
after that I'd never booked another
commercial it's just those two but I
went on hundreds of auditions well Lucca
was there Luke who's taken all the work
Michael cedar was killing it I think it
was like you know it's just like no it's
like there's a c-stand
with an X and there you do that for like
a hundred times because that's very
important but you didn't the right place
yeah and then but the whole commercial
was like a CGI extravaganza like there's
this I'm making cookies and the cookie
dough comes alive look yeah it's like
chasing the other yeah they went for it
they like kind of splurged on there and
special effects for this commercial all
right so this next one is the heartbeat
sauce
sounds good
[Music]
that's delicious actually
so when Arrested Development was reborn
in 2013 he took on an expanded role not
only as one of the show's stars but then
also a fixture in the writing room
there's a lot of lore surrounding
writers rooms I know that your
experience was limited but in that
limited experience I wonder do the good
ideas just naturally float to the top or
is there an art and being the loudest
voice in the room or a pillar man good
question um yeah I think sometimes it's
like a lot of timing if you have a good
idea maybe you shouldn't say it right
away wait you know until things kind of
there's like a lull and then pretend you
just came up with it but ya know a lot
of times the good stuff floats to the
top there is some kind of filter system
that just kind of happens naturally and
it could be I think kind of a political
thing or a personality thing it's but
there's like a balance to it you kind of
learn your place like a family almost
it's delicious that one Dom put it in
the bag yeah no kidding we'll give you
that one do I get some gifts that's cool
you do you get a little swag bag that's
awesome oh this is from Thunder Bay
Ontario and you're from Ontario I'm from
Ontario beautiful rap for the homies
yeah they're doing a nice job up there
just says pepper sauce it's a little bit
[Music]
can I ask you like um you must be kind
of like our virtue of this show like
tuned into the world of hot sauce a
little bit more than I'd like to be you
very nicely curated I have to say thank
you even the color scheme like I guess
you put some thought into Heather
it's almost chum burger who helped put
this whole thing together he has
sleepless nights every season every
season again so when you're a beloved
character that's in cult movies like
Scott Pilgrim are super bad you end up
sometimes having a persona that takes
out a life of its own have you seen the
way the Internet has made you its own
via memes and corners of Reddit do you
ever poke around does it scare you are
you fascinated by it maybe it scares me
I don't think I want to know not that I
you know it's kind of nice in a way
I'm not just a big internet guy really
your friend and super bad co-star Jonah
Hill has this larger-than-life online
persona in large part because he's like
a street style icon right have you ever
heard of Jonah Hill day yeah well from
Jonah I heard of it I was with Jonah
last week then he went to Jonah Hill day
that morning I saw I was so proud of him
I mean that's so brave it's great though
I mean I love that he did that because
it's my buddies that put it on okay
those guys mm-hmm whites and James shot
out failing upwards so when Jonah was on
Kimmel he was like I was too shy to go
the first year yeah and then the second
one it was just ringing off and he had
such a great time yeah it sounds like a
great thing to do I mean I was inspired
by Jonah doing that at first I think
it'd be scared but then it's like he had
a great time right I mean also I think
he like just got himself in the frame of
mind of like I'm just gonna go be this
girl like it's like kind of a character
or something like the person they want
you to be or that whatever your are to
them and that day just go be that I mean
it's like going and shooting something
or something it's like just kind of take
yourself outside of yourself and have
fun with it can we expect to see you in
attendance at next year's Jonah Hill day
that sounds fun I told Jonah you should
go like a like scatter when he goes like
don't go the third year go the fourth
yeah people be like oh every two years
he goes keeping going as if yeah in a
way terrorize them
so this is this guy this is the son of
zombie grant okay
I'm gonna invite first ask questions
later so they taught us in the Academy
that one is just so delicious right away
sweet so as you mentioned in your intro
you're an upcoming Broadway play called
the Waverly gallery yeah and then
earlier this year with lobby hero so
clearly it's not a one-off experiment
for you yeah what draws you back to the
stage so I was working on lobby hero
with Kenneth Lonergan who wrote it and
he also wrote Waverly gallery and then I
I think from my agent I heard that they
were doing the Waverly gallery with
Elaine May so I emailed Kenny right away
and said please let me like sweep the
floor to be there because I love Elaine
May and I found my god to have an
opportunity to work with her would be
just amazing and something I would be so
jealous of whoever got to do it if I
wasn't doing it and I would always
regret missing that chance what's the
biggest difference when you're trying to
target your next project when you're
reading a movie script versus when
you're reading a play script I mean a
play it's a big commitment of time and
you're stuck like you can't do other
things at the same time and choosing a
movie you just don't want it to be
something that people see and they are
embarrassed by I think which can happen
but it also is like who you get to where
you know who I don't know I mean like
the reason I really love acting for a
living is that you get to work with
people that are amazing that you admire
[Music]
so this next one is the lowest calientes
[Music]
we're calling it the sauce of summer hmm
that's really tasty well we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that Graham where you do a deep
dive and I guess Instagram put
interesting pictures that need more
context you do not have an Instagram
which really throws a wrench but we have
a workaround we've gone to the Gettys
and pulled some interesting michael cera
photos that just need more context I'll
just show you the picture and you tell
me the bigger story is that sound good
yeah all right laptop please great Thank
You beau you're welcome it's a funny job
you lift a giant block for the computer
on it built the light of the bill has
really grown quite a bit
first things first looks like you're
just minding your business okay that's a
story that's a crazy story that was a
horrible moment for me really yes so
this guy I used to live in Los Feliz in
Los Angeles and that was a moment when I
was like kind of famous or I had a movie
coming out or some reason why someone
would like want to photograph me and
spend their day doing that so there was
this guy like in my neighborhood
stalking me this is the only time that
has ever happened to me in my life it
was a very strange experience
he just wouldn't stop he was following
me all day I was riding around on my
bike and he was enjoying my like fear
you know it was just this like thing
where you saw this other side of people
and I was like I get it like take the
photo and go but he like enjoyed putting
me in a state of like fear or agitation
to get another kind of photo or
something I went up to his window I like
shook his hand I was like please stop
you're really scaring me now like this
is getting really weird he was like okay
that was what made it really wait he was
like yeah I got it man yeah totally I'll
leave you alone and then he kept doing
it and then I could never and then he
would just be always like a little far
away in his car I went into a movie
theater at a Los Feliz 3 and watched a
movie for two hours and came out and he
was waiting he had waited and I was like
don't follow me home man like I don't
want you to come know where I live and
like be a splinter in my you know leg
for the rest of my life so it was really
and at one point I just like got off my
bike and sat down on the curb and he
like drove by looking for me I was like
dude this is like really stressing me
out can you stop and then he like saw
that
and stopped and went away we're David I
was like this is weird
I didn't mean to dig up any trial I'm
glad I could it was years ago you know
that hasn't happened me again cuz that
enough of a bite to be fair qualifies
know us well if you don't you can go in
for another one and we'll just so that
people don't call me push so super bad
celebrated its tenth anniversary last
year what I'd like to do here is dig up
some of the lore surrounding that film
because it means so much to so many
people and you can just tell me if it's
fact or if it's fiction or if there's a
bigger story behind that so that's all
good fun all right true or false
Evan Goldberg's brother Dave drew all
the dick drawing the Stover bad mm-hmm
what's true I mean we watched the movie
like hundreds of times when it came out
we were promoting it and I think the
dicks are like at the end of the movie
over the credits mm-hmm there's a lot of
dick pictures and people that was like
perfect emotional nuttin for people
never like yes they really wanted to see
all those is it true that Christopher
mintz-plasse pissed off Jonah Hill
during the audition is there everywhere
definitely when he left the room Jonah
was like no not him what happened he was
like irritated by him I think he felt
that Chris was like kind of getting the
better of him comedic Lee stopping Jonah
like like kind of like blocking Jonah's
like funny jabs which made it so funny I
mean it made Jonah like double down and
Jonah getting irritated made him funnier
made Jonah funnier and Chris just
deflect it like he just hit he is a guy
who does not care in real life he's
really an admirable guy shrugs
everything off he does not care what
anybody thinks about him and that was
really apparent and in an audition
setting that you're like a rock star if
you have that quality no did you do an
hour-long dance for the super bail DVD I
did so that was Evan Goldberg's idea
Evans a really fun and funny and weird
guy he was I was like right when
blu-rays were like starting to happen
he was like with the blu-ray we can have
a DVD menu that the menu screen can be
an hour long and it won't loop it was
like so I want you to dance for an hour
so that somebody will watch the DVD menu
waiting for it to loop and it just like
never will until after an hour and I was
like great and then so we did that like
after a day of shooting we went into
this like studio at Sony with a green
screen and I danced for an hour non-stop
there are a million different references
to super bad and hip hop lyrics so I
want to bounce too off of you and you
can tell me which one you're prouder of
okay great so this first one is from Big
Sean I'm unusual as [ __ ] I'm super bad
your girl probably doodle in my dick and
then this next one is from Kanye West
off forever
old money Benjamin Button what nothing
now super bad chicks given me McLovin
Kanye West said that mm-hmm oh my god I
didn't know that that's cool I like the
Kanye West one Jonah told me that he met
Eminem in mm like recited the first 10
minutes of super bad to him like had it
memorized and did our voices and stuff
how did Jonah react to that you know
like really shocked like I mean when he
told me I was like it stunned by that so
weird
before we go on sure do you think I
could just floss I have like a piece of
chicken went to it and it's got too much
of my attention yeah yeah absolutely
absence do we have floss on set we're
too thick
Thanks sorry man anything no that just
don't want to be I like fighting that
and it's like still spicy every time I
try and wedge it out it's it's a big
kick yeah I'll just use here sorry I
said I'll be five seconds with it you
feel me
that's this next one is the bun stirs
Black Label it's out of Australia it's
come a long way
16 out of 10 heat that's weird
[Music]
that makes them sound kind of stupid
they don't understand man 32 say ten out
of ten
I was annoyed recently at a farmers
market because um there was this woman
selling soups and some of them were
really hot
she had a rating system she had like um
this ones are two out of five this one's
a three out of five this one's a four
out of five and you had like ten soups
but there was no five out of five I was
like then why don't you make the one
that's four out of five the five if
that's the hottest like what is five
shouldn't five be the hottest and
shouldn't that exist you have as high
numbers and no I didn't I wanted to find
her but she's a woman selling soup I'm
gonna embarrass her in front of her
potential customers walked away and
quietly said it to my mom and girlfriend
classic stupid movie alright so this
next one is the bomb it's pretty hot
historically yes
[Music]
[Music]
they make a big deal of it on the model
warning the sauce is extremely hot
consume one drop at a time with extreme
caution it's hot
stays to go into it
I like Chipotle
no problem I mean a little pain in the
mouth
it's okay
I'm fun I've done crazy [ __ ]
it's not to get too meta but I do want
to talk to you a little bit about the
dynamics of a celebrity interview
because it's something that we think
about all the time at this freak show
that you've so gamely decided to join in
on I heard you make an interesting point
about how sometimes your Hollywood
interviews can cause a bit of a
kerfuffle simply because you can't match
the gigawatt energy of whoever isn't for
you or the platform true can you explain
that for me well it's like trying to
talk normally it tongue hurts oh you're
doing like a junket and sometime
anything you have like ten people roll
through in a day I might just be
drooling and not know it
that's okay it's the show and um yeah
everybody kind of that's like they're 10
minutes and they were like sometimes
prepared a bit that you haven't signed
off on and you have no interest in
participating and you think you're just
there as a human being to talk about
your movie which is pretty boring
granted but sometimes you just don't
think they have any taste and now I'm
like forced to like go along with it or
else I'm like throwing a wrench in your
thing and I seem like I'm not fun
sometimes if you just don't want to go
with their energy you've seen like a
confrontational [ __ ] or something but
to go with their energy would be worse I
think you'd seem like a total [ __ ] so
I kind of lose lose no listen I can act
with it as a guy who hosts a show where
we have 10 scorching hot chicken wings
laid out in front of our guests yeah
when of the scorching hot ones concerned
Oh
[Music]
this is one really slow build or cuz
it's not as hot as the previous one I
find yes but we order by the skull bleep
oh okay yeah I saw you talking to Padma
thought the Scoville unit oh wow
there you go and I really enjoyed your
thoughts about it or her thoughts which
was like it's kind of like an imaginary
measurement exactly exactly so in
addition to being one of the most famous
actors in Hollywood I know that you're
very much a film buff a student of the
game so what I want to do is give you a
series of universal life moments that
may be the power of film could help
someone through and then you try to
recommend a movie like Chris Lawrence's
kind of life moment exactly that's
challenging them is there a movie that
you'd recommend to a kid who's feeling
like an outcast
I feel so on the spot well the Sandlot
comes to mind right away but the lesson
in that movie is kind of hard it's like
well just find a group of friends that
you fit in perfectly with and you'll be
happy if you're stuck in a rut of your
day-to-day existence you want to expand
your mind what film would Michael Cera
pull off the shelf a rut of day-to-day
existence and something that's like a
fantasy thing I guess maybe world on a
wire
the Fassbender movie just cuz that's
like a really fun science fiction movie
can you give me a movie that you'd
recommend when you're tripping balls and
psychedelic mushrooms fantastic planet
be fun
something animated or like spirited away
I just watch that with my niece it's a
little scary for kids I think I got it
for her for her eighth birthday and we
were watching and like halfway through I
was kind of like is this too scary but I
think she was a little disturbed by it
all right Michael Cera all right so this
is the last dab
we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing okay you don't
have to if you don't want to I will
which should be no problem for you my
friends I was with my friends last night
mm-hmm and they're a couple and they
have a bet one of them whether I'll
finish this really yeah
one is against me one is for me it
almost detects them after the one who's
against you what an idiot looking like
an idiot
yeah underestimation all right
and then you bite right on the sauce you
bite right on the sauce and that would
be the point right but before you do
yeah here we are at our hot sauce
journey's end and you're so expressive
you can say so much without even so much
as uttering a word so what we're going
to do here is we're going to stimulate
our bodies with a bajillion scovilles
and then follow the journey of pepper X
entirely through facial expressions okay
[Music]
got it
you're doing great nice for you I can
break I can't lie I love that like how
much happens into the space of a second
that we don't really realize we'd love
to watch like a 10-minute version of all
this stuff you just did
well that's lupus Prince our put it on
the next DVD menu and look at you
Michael Cera I don't know who your
friend is you said she couldn't keep the
board this will get you look at you you
King all the way through ten chicken
wings up ten chicken wings down bright
red red in the face a little bit
glowing around the eyes nice honestly
think that it's like a reborn Michael
Cera okay looking so good I would love
to swim right now this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
right away all right guys I'm gonna do
this play on Broadway with Elaine May
and we're gonna go until January god
bless her she's 86 I think and she's
gonna give an amazing amazing historical
performance to us and nobody should miss
it especially if you love her as much as
I do what she should my floss chips yeah
is it like you get I yeah yeah you do
like cuz like even sometimes on the show
like I always make this joke that like
that's why it's keeping us going is that
Jason but it's true like sometimes I'll
go be like I have like a nice little
head brush
yeah you know yeah but then same with
the pepper is that like when you eat a
Carolina Reaper yeah it's sort of drug
like and yeah but then you go home yeah
yeah but then you go home and then
you're just in the fetal position
basically giving yourself food poisoning
and then it's you know it's it's it's
it's kind of exhilarating Hey
oh hey spice Lords come here I want to
let you in on a little secret you
already know about the hot ones
subscription box every month we send you
three of the best damn hot sauces you've
ever had in your life but this is the
big announcement the moment you've been
waiting for the thing that people will
not stop tweeting me about if you want
the last abra ducks with chocolate
pepper X and pepper X the way to do it
sign up for a hot one subscription box
before August 15th if you already get
the subscription box you're good to go
throw your feet up the last dab with
track of pepper ax and pepper ax it's on
its way to your doorstep but if you want
to be one of the first people to get it
the way to do it sign up for a hot one
subscription box you already know the
drill heat nice calm heat nice calm to
sign up who appreciates his spice Lords
I do what the no don't dad me bro ah
[Music]